you know netflix is reportedly working
on it to all the boys spin-off series
that's centered around
kitty what do you know about it or what
do you make of that whoa
um man i think that
kitty i think it would totally make
sense i think kitty is just one of the
i mean she's truly just a scene stealer
and catherine
that was weird that's not my name kitty
well i mean catherine's kind of my name
but people don't call me that call me
kitty
no one has approached me about it or so
i don't really know
anything about it but i remember the
press
um junket for the third movie everyone
was asking her like
is this something that you would be
interested in i would totally support it
if it's something that
comes to light we'll have to wait to see
the next chapter of to all the boys
but in the meantime lana condor is
hosting this year's
virtual costume designers guild awards
how much fun was it for you to decide
what to wear for this
it was so fun this is the show that you
can really just kind of go all
out and really be fun and celebrate and
take risks
um in fashion and and be loud in fashion
i wish that the show was like 10 times
longer
so i could have like one billion costume
changes but you know what we're
we're we're you know i'll settle i'll
settle obviously because of your job you
get to
interact and collaborate with a lot of
amazing designers and stylists
how has that experience influenced your
own style but i think that like
in my personal kind of day-to-day style
like i'm learning
so much from my stylist and i feel like
something that's like very huge and
important to me is
particularly during this time but always
has been is to wear
pieces or support small locally owned
businesses particularly ones that are
um that have asian designers
um and and i feel like that's a huge
part of
something that's so important to me
because i think what you wear is a
really um
it's an extension of yourself it's an
extension of your own personality and i
really
realized when i was doing the tall boys
movies that
her she dresses and very like
much louder than she is as a real human
as like
just her persona and i think it's just a
way to express
like your inner you know you know your
inner whatnots and so
something that's like important is to
for me to wear clothes that i
feel emotionally connected with the
world keeps shifting under my feet
all i want is for it to stand still i
gotta tell you the third installment of
to all the boys i loved before was
exactly what my heart needed but it also
made me sad because it's over
yeah you were the face of this beloved
franchise which by the way
put a fierce female asian character at
the forefront
i mean now that your time on the
franchise for now is done what would you
say has been the most rewarding part
about being uh
you know being part of this amazing and
impactful role
the biggest blessing that has come from
all of it is
the people that i get to meet on the
streets who
come up to me at trader joe's let's say
or like whatever and they come up to me
and they
immediately want to share with me their
the way that they could relate to the
films and the way that they were seen
and represented in those films and so i
learned so much about strangers like
like just so much about strangers and i
think that's something that i've always
loved i love people and i
and i love to hear their stories so i
think that has been a really really big
gift and it's also given me
you know the opportunity to you know
host the show which is crazy like i
never
thought that like i would be doing this
i'm curious as you begin your next
chapter in your career
how are you using your platform and your
voice to propel
asian talent in particular or asian
stories moving forward
and it might sound a little bit dramatic
but
i do believe that i was put on this
earth
to make people feel a little less alone
like i believe that
i love to entertain people but i want to
do it in a way
that feels like
meaningful and feels like people can be
seen and not feel
um weirder or
not or ostracized in any way so moving
forward
and i've done this throughout my career
but now more than ever
moving forward the projects that i have
lined up all
show fully flushed three dimensional
beautiful
asian american stories
and are not
leaning into the stereotypes or the
false narratives that i think
i've heard before in
the world and so i'm very specific about
what i choose because i
i it representing is
not something that i shy away from it's
something that i
genuinely feel like is my passion and
something that i love
is there anything that you're seeing out
there from the asian american community
that
gets you excited about the future
there's been a lot of sorrow
and a lot of heaviness and
i and a lot to process and
grieve and work through but i always try
and see a little bit of a silver lining
seeing you know friends and family and
even people marching in the street that
i don't know coming to me
and and even if they didn't know what's
been going on coming to me and being
like i'm
so sorry and now i know and now i'm
going to
continue to shut
the hatred down so that makes me
hopeful that makes me hopeful that we
are being ignored
as much as i think the violence against
asians
have been in the past i'm seeing a lot
of
people who i never really even thought
would reach out
or would care or have these
conversations with their families do so
so i think that that is really
you know um i think that that is that's
that silver lining and i i choose to be
optimistic because if i
if i'm not then i'm not going to get out
of bed right so i
so yeah i think more now than ever it's
so important to preserve
to protect and to celebrate the aapi
community especially in hollywood so
someone's got to do it and i'm glad it's
you you just got to step in the room and
be like come on people get your life do
[Music]
it
you